Hóa tổng thống Wey Trudevans, nè hôm tri tháng 8.0, Washington đã đều phần lớn một tiêu trong trái sịch quả sự nhà bởi văn và đáng bước phà dở đoạn cuối.
Theo ông, tổng thống Mi đưa đơn trăm sự kiến suy trì ngoài đập của sự thêm 1 thời gian ngắn để bảo đàn các một tiêu trữ ợp được hoàn tất.
Chứ khi giúp lực lợp, ông Văn sống nhận mạnh một tiêu chính của Washington,
là làm suy giảm nâng lợp quân sự cuối văn và ngăn trảm trị trình hẳng nhăn.
Đồng thời thần định Mỹ không cối định suy trị hệ dễ quân sự kéo sài tại Cô Vực.
Chỉ quyền Mỹ cũng châu sàng ra đoạn kinh tế như giảm năng gượng tăng, chỉ mang tính tạm thơ lệ và sẽ sế sế một định trở lại.
Còn ngày bộ tư lệ trường Mỹ có bối hình nèng tất của tấn công, nhằm gần lực lượng thải quân yвang,
châu sàng tất mối đi giòa đồ về văn tài hàng thải chung Cô Vực hiện đáng được kiểm soát.
Về viên yвang tất dụng bố gần đây cho thấy tề văn và suy trì lập trường tướng sáng,
và chưa sức nhận khả năng chấm dứt dụng cho bố cạnh giáo trang tất dụng dịnh biển tất cả.